Alle 250 tausend jahre etwa wechselt das magnetfeld unserer erde seine richtung dort statistik kann es also wirklich nicht mehr lange dauern
Dass es wieder passiert und das hätte fatale folgen für uns alle ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht hier bekommen wir es
Was also darauf hindeutet dass tatsächlich eine umpolung des erdmagnetfeldes bevorsteht was überhaupt
Zum innenleben der erde wissen und welche konsequenzen solch eine umpolung der erde für das leben auf er hätte jetzt in klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
Immer mal wieder gab es in der langen erdgeschichte eine umpolung des magnetfeldes durchschnittlich alle
250.000 jahren das letzte mal als es seine richtung gewechselt hat das ist allerdings schon
786 1000 jahre her heißt also
hätte man damals eine kompassnadel die richtung anzeigen lassen hätte sie nicht nach norden sondern nach wilden gezeigt damals
passierte es innerhalb von echt schnellen 100 jahren glaubt man
Also der statistik sollte dieses dramatische ereignis demnächst mal wieder anstehen also eigentlich ist überfällig und jahr schätzungen zufolge nimmt die stärke
Des erdmagnetfeldes derzeit um 5 prozent ab pro jahrhundert dazu die europäische, weltraumorganisation esa die
Feldstärke hat sich in den letzten 150 jahren um zehn prozent verringert wird es bei dieser zerfalls rate bleiben müsste es rein rechnerisch in
1600 jahren gänzlich verschwunden sein
Forschungsteams weltweit nehmen das thema
jedenfalls sehr ernst
Doch viel können sie nicht tun und der grund dafür ist nun eigentlich ziemlich krass wir wissen kaum etwas über das innenleben der erde
genauso wenig wie über einen richtungswechsel des
Erdmagnetfeldes das einzige was wir wissen ist im inneren der erde sorgen ströme aus geschmolzenem eisen für das sonst noch
So unerforschte magnetfeld jetzt hat ein forschungsteam von der university ließ die dynamik
im erdinneren genauer untersucht und zwar mit hilfe der europäischen satelliten smos
Diese satelliten mission der esa beinhaltet drei satelliten die die erde auf polaren umlaufbahn
Umkreisen und dabei messen wie stark das erdmagnetfeld ist wie es sich
Orientiert und auch ob es sich zeitlich verändert die mission wurde ende letzten jahres bis ins jahr 2000
21 verlängert durch die verschiedenen perspektiven der insgesamt drei satelliten ist es möglich andere
Magnetfelder wie etwa aus der erdkruste
herauszurechnen
die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler konnten also tatsächlich beobachten wie das flüssige eisen
3000 kilometer unter der erdoberfläche
Fließt dabei machten sie eine erstaunliche entdeckung und zwar fanden sie einen eisen strom der sich von russland bis nach
Nordamerika steigt dabei dreht er sich westlich und kreisförmig
Um den nordpol und überraschend ist tatsächlich seine geschwindigkeit der etwa
429 kilometer breite reisen strom bewegt sich rund 40 kilometer pro jahr was dreimal schneller ist als alle anderen
strömungen im erdinneren
kurios ist auch ein weiteres ergebnis des britischen forschungsteams der eisen strom unter russland und
nordamerika ist in den letzten jahren immer schneller geworden um die geschwindigkeit
des stroms zu berechnen bande das forschungsteam einen kleinen trick an denn dies machen die swarm
-satelliten alleine nicht möglich weil unter sibirien und kanada 2 hot spots mit einem extrem
ausgeprägten magnetfeld liegen und sich diese hotspots mit dem strom bewegen war auch die analyse der genauen geschwindigkeit möglich
das fehlen eines soll stark hotspots auf der südhalbkugel hat es bislang unmöglich gemacht auch auf der südhalbkugel
einen ähnlichen eisen strom zu lokalisieren obwohl das britische forschungsteam von seiner existenz überzeugt ist
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler weltweit jedenfalls sind run möglichst zeitnah noch mehr zu diesem kuriosen
Prozessen, im erdinneren zu erfahren und ich habe es eben schon kurz erwähnt das verständnis der wissenschaft dazu ist wirklich ziemlich gering
bislang und das könnte fatale konsequenzen haben falls wirklich eine solche umpolung
des erdmagnetfeldes geschieht denn das magnetfeld der erde
Schützt das leben auf ihr vor der gefährlichen kosmischen strahlung bei einer umpolung würde es sich wohl
deutlich abschwächen die krebsgefahr für menschen und tiere wäre dann deutlich erhöht auch beim fliegen
werden wir also einer deutlich höheren strahlung ausgesetzt ein zusammenbruch würde zudem wohl die weltweiten strom und
Kommunikationsnetze, zum kollaps bringen auch satelliten würden ausfallen wie sonst nur bei sonnenstürmen ja wenn er als erster neues zum thema
Und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von pixum mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder
fragen zu videos stellen der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
Riesiger rätselhafte lichtbogen über der erde ansonsten würde ich mal wieder sagen bis dann
bleibt dran